inspired by my most famous meme what are
you what are
you comes an outrageous competition that
finally separates the col genius from
the idiot oh my gosh here at Caesar
Palace in Las Vegas three contestants
will go head-to-head to create a
sandwich that will take the Internet by
storm but there's just one hurdle to
overcome me I'm fry g i let's go only
the person who impressed me the most
I've never wanted anything more in my
life will walk away being crowned my
idiot
sandwich first give it up for R give it
up for
link and give it up for my Nemesis man
we got some beef to settle Josh ladies
and gentlemen somebody's going to take
him down you guys are you ready I hope
so yeah is Vegas
ready gentlemen your time starts
now right uh now I've got some beak to
settle uh these two comedians are
amazing uh R and Link are extraordinary
now they've been practicing endless hey
you jerks I'm starting with the bread
cuz I know what a sandwich makes one of
my key strategies bribe the audience
with a pickle who wants the
pickle but today my eyes are on Josh
because he is a prolific chef but more
importantly this guy has done nothing
but called me out for the last two years
Gordon that was a trash grilled cheese
you're a fancy little Victorian boy
who's the real donut here Gordon it's
you I'm sorry punch me in the face
Daddy I've brought my own hogy roll yeah
stop it seriously you don't trust me I
no no I trust you you know it's just the
environments I got I'm going to get this
I'm makinging a caride of cheese steak
love that I thought about making you
something British but I was like no I
want to play to my flavors I love that
now tell me the layers what's going on
here what you going okay layers RI eye
going to slice that really thin I'm
going to get it marinating with a bunch
of Mexican spices cumin chili powder
maybe a little warm spice like cinnamon
black pepper garlic Josh is falling for
the Trap of just talking talking talking
talking going to add some onion and
fresh Bano chili in there let that sit
for a sec he's not making
anything of course I'm talking and not
making anything either hit that super
hot and fast I'm making a h Chipotle
homemade cheese whz I'm using sodium
citrate to actually bind it instead of
doing a mnet both because time and also
gives a really vality texture a little
bit of quick pickled onions with
habanero and oregano on top I can't wait
to taste it good luck m i two minutes
gone let's go who wants a pickle you
want a pickle over there right link how
we doing uh I'm doing good I'm I'm
making up making bacon I love that so
you crisping the bacon tell me the sand
what we going to be doing oh I'm I'm I'm
going to work you some ham magic with a
little bit of turkey magic ham turkey
bacon sound good and a little bit of
cheese cheese are we toasting the bread
uh no no no toast why' you why why why
would you ask that just I could deep fry
the bread cuz I have that no no no just
hoping it stays nice and crispy so it
doesn't get too saly but I I need and
I'm I'm using this which I don't know if
I don't know if it needs to be diagnosed
or something but a it's very soft lots
of but very soft 15 minutes to together
said he said lots of butter I wasn't
planning on using any butter okay oh he
turned this
sof I think he helped me I'll accept it
right RS how you doing season flour
we're doing good give me an inside of
the sandwich where we going so you're
dressing the chicken the chicken so this
is going to be a a hot chicken sandwich
but it's a BC hot chicken sandwich BC
stands for blue cheese and buo Creek the
town that I grew up in okay but the key
to this thing yes really setting off is
the blue cheese sloth I love um how
confident are you beating Josh because
you guys are super compettive but this
guy's a he's in he's in a different
league right I'm so conflicted about it
because he he actually works for me as a
chef so it's actually bad for my brand
but good for my ego if I beat him key to
this is you've got to take the meat and
you've got to like Swirl It 14 minutes
to go this is global cooking I'm going
to let the salt sit in there marinate
that I'm trying to crush up the meat of
course this is going to be better than a
Gordon Ramsay sandwich I mean come on
the guys from England they travel the
world for spices decided to use none of
them and I'm going to get om the cheese
sauce boys I got to run use the proper
tool mlin use the Whisk
mlin who are you reaching for I think we
like link over link he's good he's very
cool I want to chop this lettuce
up perfect sandwich what is it perfect
sandwich yes please probably a chicken
BLT a chicken BLT who you rooting for
we're fting for red R why red cuz he
looked just like me he does he's got it
my man who wants a
[Applause]
pickle I love a good BLT y'all good
y 12 minutes to go come on help me out
give me give me some moral
support yeah yeah yeah yeah you probably
have picked up on it already but link is
a I got so excited to put way too
much pepper on my sandwich The Uncanny
thing about link is he has found a way
of making being a like
his brand and actually it helps me make
money we make money when link is a
eight minutes to go guys 8 minutes
to go hey thr me have an hour um have an
hour you can go there to me have an hour
now you're treating me like a little
seriously we're each other's
little I know but really seriously
we can be mutual little win this
thing I'll get you a jalapeno trust me
come on Focus three extraordinary
sandwiches by the way um I love the idea
of rep he's going down this um thigh
chicken thigh with his blue cheese
obsessed with blue cheese and it sounds
really good um Link Link I'm slightly
concerned about I think I think there's
a missing big Link in his sandwich he's
playing it safe however Josh is cutting
Ed cutting cutting Ed cut the only thing
needs cutting is your
hair just a little trim keep it out of
the sandwich please link look at that
he's clearly imitating me uh but Josh is
back with a vengeance and more
importantly that guy's got his eyes on
the prize toasted cheese oh is there a
torch how does this work hey show me how
to work this anybody know how to use a
torch so chickens get nice and crispy
right yeah and using the thigh was that
yeah y good too much brown sugar in it
so this is going to be our hot chicken
sauce gotcha got all kind of glaze on
there we got cayenne pepper cayenne
pepper I love the idea of the blue
cheese SLO love that I think that might
be gas coming out that's just gas girl
you're a man of refined taste so I'm
assuming that you do like blue cheese
you're not like link who has no taste
Whats no no no no I'm bit conf bit
confused about link he's just doing like
turkey sandwich hey here's the thing if
you know him as well as I do there's
nothing confusing about it at all which
we can get anywhere but this one over
here is super competitive you breeded a
monster you know that oh oh my God
unfreaking real he's a man of mini words
most about food usually you know and
himself he's not short of that he is uh
link can you concentrate please I'm
trying to figure out how to work this a
blowtorch is it is that gas or is that
blame okay now I'm going to get some uh
you can't get the audience to help you
that's cheating come on oh my
gosh oh my gosh did you see that I
figured it out 90 seconds to go guys
come on give it up for these amazing
individuals come on guys bring home Josh
here I go I'm melting the cheese like
you said brushing the chicken 60 seconds
to go Josh got that synthetic cheese on
there be careful not too much Josh
Gordon never 15 seconds to go I got to
do something creative yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes I think Gordon's going to be
very impressed I got a lot of fun
flavors in here secret weapon just a
little more crunch for the gourd
daddy 10 9 8 7 7 6 5 4 3 2
amazing I swear to God my hands are
clean-ish my hands are clean is you guys
roll you guys roll thank you all so much
I got four more
pickles hey what are you doing you you
I'm giving out pickles no this is my
people man I'm winning your people over
with pickles come on guys you can't be
so petty to be swayed by
here you go here you go give me that
pickle anybody just want pickle juice
right uh well done now for the most
exciting part the taste test R so let's
start with you uh describe the sandwich
please okay so this is the buoys Creek
blue cheese hot chicken sandwich we have
a chicken thigh with some seasoned flour
we have some secret sauce on the bottom
layer we have some pickles and then we
have the secret the thing that really
sets us apart we have the blue cheese
SLO blue cheese SLO visually it looks
delicious that looks good very good
indeed okay shall
we oh my God it's crunchy yeah it's hot
it's got that nice tartness with the
sour and the blue cheese I love the
SLO it's good oh thanks man it's very
good wow
wow
wow you ready I you ready to eat a real
sandwich I am nervous when you got a
blow torch in your hand I'm nervous when
you got a knife in your hand I'm even
nervous when you got a Peppermill in
your hand um tell me what is this well
there's some ham there's some turkey
there's some bacon right there's some
provolone a there's some lettuce there's
some uh salt and then lots of pepper
because they were really cheering me on
when I was grinding the pepper
but I love pepper should we get in now
bacon nice and crispy let's have a look
at that inside yeah yeah yeah oh yes
yeah look at yes yes yes please cheers
bu thank it shall
we M it's good it's good
good I will confess watching you 20
minutes in the kitchen you scare the
out of me
man
right Josh time Reckoning is coming man
okay look at that uh visually that is uh
that's appetizing it looks good uh tell
me what do we got so here we have a
carada cheese steak a combination of two
of my favorite foods in the world I took
rii marinated it with a bunch of spices
pablanos and onions seared that off in
the skillet really quickly we have a
toasted sesame seed hogy roll we have a
Chipotle uh mouret sauce that is bound
with sodium citrate and then some quick
pickled h and oregano white onion
cilantro lime oh boy shall we absolutely
cheers Bud cheers
man my
God uh it's good thank you it's sloppy
it's delicious the heat I think what
makes this one is the pickles yeah well
done Bud good job ladies and gentlemen
come on give it
up wow three phenomenal delicious
sandwiches only one could be crowns is
it R ladies and gentlemen is it is it
links is it
[Applause]
joshes the idiot swich goes
[Music]
to
Jo finally we did it g just did you baby
what are you an idiot sandwich louder an
idiot sandwich Jeff Ramy give it up for
Josh
everybody good job really good job thank
you so much for watching these amazing
idiots looking for the ultimate idiot
sandwich well click on this video and
see what we've cooked
[Music]
up